Somebody is trying to compromise
the security of your system,
somebody who is not authorized is
trying to access your sensitive data.
How can they attack,
if what's they're asked to attack or
what they're allowed to
attack is the authentication
part of whatever security
you have in your system.
So authentication is how you start.
So the target of the attacker here
is going to be how you authenticate.
In particular,
what they're going to try to do is
defeat the authentication system.
So Eve is going to try to be successful
in authenticating herself as Alice.
In that case,
you would have successfully
compromised the authentication method.
So we're going to do this threat
modeling saying well what can they do.
What can the bad guy or that hacker do.
Well, let's just sort of talk
about the password method.
So remember the password
method is something you know.
And we all know what passwords are.
So let's say passwords are being
used by users to login to a system.
What kind of threats do we
need to be concerned about?
Well, it's a secret that's
shared between you and
the system, well,
someone can try to guess that secret.
So one threat is the not
having good passwords
that can be easily guessed by attackers.
That's one threat we have
to be concerned about,
authentication that is
based on passwords.
So this is kind of interesting.
It really is not talking about, how can
you be a user, guess their password, or
steal their token.
But it's talking about
impersonating a real login program.
So think about you come in,
and we're talking with passwords,
you provide your password to the system.
How do you know you're really
talking to the system?
How do you know it's not a program
that is impersonating the system?
All it has to do depending on which
system you have, it has to display
login, call in, or something like that
for you to provide your login ID.
Or login name and
then it has to display password colon so
you can type your password, or
whatever the interface that you have.
The is a Trojan horse,
this a program that is impersonating
the system at the other end.
Then what this program is able to do is,
as you type your password,
it'll be able to steal it.
So what's the last one?
We're talking about someone trying
to steal your password, isn't it?
If your computer is infected,
in particular if it is infected with
malicious software called keyloggers.
They are able to capture
the keys that you press,
you are going to provide your
password by pressing a bunch of keys.
And so keylogger grabs your password,
okay, so if your are doing a password
method, bad guy has to get hold of
your password, so they become you.
They can guess it, they can steal it,
either using a piece of software that
fools you into believing that you're
giving your password to
the operating system.
Or it could run as the real login
program is running and steal these keys
that you press or the characters that
you press that make up your password.